all right so thank you everyone for
joining us today
it's my pleasure to welcome you all to
today's amazing psionic session
um
i hope that all of you can
see me hear me and see my presentation
well so if everything's a positive just
put a plus sign or yes or one in the
chat section so that i get the
confirmation that i am audible to you my
voice is reaching to you and you guys
can also see my presentation perfectly
fine
so if that's the case then please let me
know in the chat section and then we
will begin with today's session
great so i got the confirmation that
everything is fine and that is the green
signal for me to begin with today's
session once again from the bottom of my
heart and on the behalf of the entire
team of psionics and fine biotech i
welcome you all to today's great psionic
session so before we move on and learn
about the exciting things that we have
in store for all of you today i would
like to introduce you to psionics who we
are what we do and how did we form
what's our vision and what's our goal
so
my name is subrajet barua and i am the
president of the psionic student club i
am a master student
at itunes university in saint petersburg
where i am studying biotechnology with
the majors in bioinformatics and the
vice president of psionic student club
is ms ruth raja who is a graduate in
biotechnology and medical sciences and
also is a past research intern in
bioinformatics from michigan state
university usa
so
before we move on let me introduce to
psionics well cyanics is not only a club
but it's a community
more precisely it's a family of more
than 1 000 students with 20 plus experts
and researchers and a proud community of
more than 30 alumni who have been a part
of this club been associated with us for
a long long time and now they are
leaving their mark in the global
community outside where they are
contributing to various pharmaceutical
industries various
institutions organizations they are
sharing their knowledge and they are
making all of us proud
so what's the vision of
scion makes of informatics student club
well
our vision lies in assisting students in
being that
guide that friend that everyone wants
from other people so at sciomix we help
each other clear the concepts of
bioinformatics to gain insights on how
to use mathematics tools how to apply
them to extract meaningful results and
also how to interpret those results
apply the knowledge of bioinformatics
and biology in day-to-day life we also
have several brainstorming sessions to
help one another overcome challenges and
help in the projects wherever they are
stuck we also help each other learn
various scores in bioinformatics and
also gain data science skills so
our areas of focus
are very diverse we are interested in
infectious diseases microbes and
microbiome neuroscience plant science
precision oncology even space zombies or
astro biology and at psionics in the
past we have also had sessions on
helping students
get admitted to various universities
studying abroad what are the challenges
how to overcome that sharing expert
comments sharing students journeys
student stories so we are such a
community which looks after each and
every need of students and helping them
in every step that they take
to
inch closer to that goal which they have
set for themselves
so before we move on let me also
introduce you to the term omix logic so
what omis logic is you will be hearing
this thermomix logic for a number of
times today so the omics logic is an
initiative by finding biotech whose goal
is to provide training in bioinformatics
to students and not only a traditional
way of training these students but also
enabling them to perform independent
research guided by mentors as well as
pure examples
and while we do this we also develop a
huge community of both
enthusiastic students as well as expert
faculties all throughout the globe which
is now a very huge community to be
honest
and also we enable students to be able
to assist clinicians
faculties of all backgrounds and develop
novel and independent research using the
latest technologies which has a high
impact in today's dnh
so
right now the top of the hour at find
biotech and almonds logic and also
cyanics is the upcoming omics research
symposium which is an international
symposium or conference which is dated
to be held on march of 31st
and april 1st 2022
well
i will introduce you to the research
symposium what it is and why are we
getting together so
while
training students and making these
connections and communities we have
formed a huge network of students
faculties and experts all over the globe
who are working actively in various
domains they are
involved in various projects they are
doing some cutting-edge science so the
omics resource symposium is aimed at
bringing together these people on a
common platform where they can share
their research experiences their
advancements and whatever they have been
experiencing
uh consult various experts on the
challenges and opportunities and also
network with one another through this
symposium various students have got the
opportunity of doing an internship
abroad or even getting admitted to
various laboratories and universities so
that's the kind of the broader aim of
the army social symposium
and apart from the keynote speakers and
all the expert lectures that is
definitely a part of the homicide
symposium there is also an opportunity
for young students and professionals to
showcase their recent projects as a part
of the poster competition so this is the
image that you're seeing from last
year's posters competition and these are
the winners who got cash prizes for
their poster
poster sessions and even this time there
is three different prizes which i will
be also highlighting towards the end of
today's webinar and how you can register
for these competitions and the best ones
will
walk away with a good amount of cash
prizes so that's the exciting part for
students and younger professionals at
the same time you also get to network
and listen to these experts from in both
academia as well as industries
very quickly i would like to highlight
the three
different
aspects of the symposium which includes
the new advancements in enabling
technologies the various carrier
opportunities and also the post
representation which we will be
highlighting
again later
so we will be having various experts
from all the reputed academic
institutions such as the universities
the various industries and also our
networks which we will again highlight
towards the end of the simple towards
the end of this webinar today
um
as i mentioned we will we are having
a plethora of great panelists from
many reputed organizations such as
google faba blue marble space institute
of science and university lc japan and
more more and more
we can go on but
now without any further ado let me
proceed and here's a poster presentation
competition that i was saying so on your
screen you can see the last year's three
best posters
uh this time we have four different
categories of poster submissions such as
omnics and mathematics
artificial intelligence machine learning
and data science astrobiology and
spaceonics and computational biology and
biotechnological industries and pharma
industries
and these are the three prizes which are
catchphrases that you can walk away with
namely best poster presentation the
citizen science project and the young
sheldon award
so that was a very long and detailed
introduction i suppose which i think
must have
given you or warmed you up for the
exciting session that we have planned
today so today we have with us maria
victoria news who is an innovation
project intern at biomena's in brazil as
well as a very talented and hardworking
content writing internet find biotech
whose
uh writing has not only mesmerized us at
mybiotic but also the world is seeing
our feeling that impact so we are really
glad to have her in our team and on
board with us
today she will be talking about the
various resources for getting trained in
bioinformatics on your own beyond the
curriculum that you face in your
universities so she will be giving you
some examples from
uh sneak
sneak peeks into the omics logic
resources from its logic courses and
training programs that we have which you
can take at your own pace uh completely
asynchronously and she will be also
guiding on what are the outcomes what
where her experiences so far
and
how can people in her community
specifically in the latin americas can
benefit from these resources so as i
understand today's session will be held
mostly in portuguese
or which
might be in some
spanish and we might also expect some
english so
it's going to be a very diverse and
international session today
so language is not a barrier to
convey the message and i'm really proud
to have this session today um without
any further ado
let's
get
started with the session and i am more
than happy to pass on the podium to
maria
the stage is all yours maria and
it's my pleasure to have you here how
are you doing
thank you
good night everyone in brazil in another
[Music]
country i don't know exactly but good
night
so
um everyone can see the presentation
it is fine
well
um first of all
i hope everyone is doing well
the sessions aims to bring to latin
america especially brazil
the tools that the omixlogic platform
can offer its courses
and resources in addition to several
opportunities um to come
so for all of my brazilian friends here
if you
do not understand something or if you
want to ask some question in portuguese
no problem we are here for it
um
as
he said
my name is maria victoria luz
i am the
last semester of biotechnology
bachelor's degree at university of
brasilia and i'm currently an intern in
innovation products
at biomina's brazil that is
a pioneer in supporting biobusiness in
brazil
i am content writing intern for pine
biotech
and i'm also a mentor for of the
powerful girls program at the
us
embassy and consulates in brazil that
aims to bring leadership and
entrepreneurship for girls from public
schools
it is a pleasure to introduce the
founders and members of the company
um so you can contact one of us on
linkedin
for example
because of that i wanted to show you
um dr alfred dr leonid brodsky
dr mohit
um priya
and also
uh subi regit
that is my
supervisor
he is a scientific outreach coordination
coordinator
and
all of them have different background
and um
they are specialists in
different areas so
the platform
is a very diverse and
multi-disciplinary for example dr alfred
comes from a medical background
specializing in oncology immunology and
inflammation biochemistry
brodzky is the director of the tauber
bioinformatics research center
and
he is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
and and we have julia panoff and she is
a bioinformatics expert and avi
that is leading the
development of the t bioinfo platform
which we were going to show you how it
works
so
what
time biotech is what
amex logic is i will
say something
for you in portuguese to understand
how it works and how you can learn
because
biotech is a company in us based in
bioinformatics
so
they work with a bio
very variety of academics and industry
and industry contributors so
um
varus passed
a
um
[Music]
so
the vision of pine biotech is to improve
human health and well-being by
enabling biological research and
discover relevant data data
uh so the company offers
hands-on learning
and it's like something easy to learn
by yourself
and more
people um
are going to be prepared for research in
that data driven way and
because of that
i think that is a great way to
democratize bioinformatics around the
world and
omex logic is a program that works with
data driven concepts into biological
designs
explaining the students learning journal
journey from observer
to research participant so
this journey is beginning by
find an interesting and biological
research um so you choose a problem and
then you
can answer these through bioinformatics
um
and you learn about the data collections
and organizations
and the end
um you will be able to
uh interpret interpreting and drawing
conclusions from these data
so
omix logic training programs
are the result of several collaborations
as i talked to you
before
so
it's interesting because
um
have some some of content assessment
curriculum review project design
it's like a lot of things in different
ways in the platform
and
this is possible because over the past
years the company worked with various
organizations
and
right now
um complete by over
uh 15
thousand participants
sent to essentia space oil
using
workshops
do
and
when i come in as an intern at pine
biotech
i wanted to bring the people that
live around me that live in the same
conditions as i live
these great opportunities
so
everything you need to get started and
grow
in the platform there are contexts and
how there are tests and videos and they
are divided into several modules
so
you are going to learn something do an
exercise watch some videos
read some articles and this way you are
achieving some
topics and gaining points
and
they work with
some
visual interface that helps link
individual algorithms and bioinformatics
pipelines while learning about data
analysis data analysis
this is pipeline
[Music]
right
uh i'll stop
oh
platform
um
all right
um
when you enter in the platform and has
several courses from bioinformatics
to precision medicine
multi-omics including genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics and you also can learn using
r and python
and you can have access to these several
workshops and lectures
that we are seeing today
so
here you can see
some of the omics logic
courses for those who are interested in
coding and are only to in applying the
the tools offered by
the platform you can also learn to code
here
some of the research fellowship programs
so you
will develop an independent research
project and learn to
to use big data analysis tools
and
and you also get access to several
things
and this was one of the projects such as
um
sarcoscope 2 genomics modeling cancer
precision medicine
and also
um
single cell
rna sac
and it's very interesting and
you can
see on website
this fellowship pro project
and
the tea bio info platform was created to
help
prepare bioprofessionals for the
large multi-omics data set they have to
deal with one
on their own without
relying on technical support to figure
computing environment and pipelines for
processing so the simple to use solution
can help train and prepare anyone with a
set of biological data for advanced
computational analysis
visualization and annotation
so
to learn more our
experience the tbio info platform
you can register for free
demo account
and connect with one of the
representatives and now i would like to
invite to be ready
and to show you all a demo of the t bio
info server
thank you so much maria that was a
really wonderful
presentation and i thoroughly enjoyed it
even though i don't understand the
language
i'm
after after all
i can i can answer some questions for
those who don't understand portuguese
but in portuguese i was talking about um
things that impact
my brazilian public
like um
free things and et cetera and then i
would like to after your talk about the
t bioinfo info platform
about the symposium because i think that
we have great
bioinformaticians here and they can
interest get interested by
so
it's yours
thank you so much well
the message was really absolutely clear
and
that's the main target so i will quickly
show
the t by n for platform which maria was
talking about
um so
first of all this is the learning
platform that you can see on my screen
which has all the courses and all the
specialization tracks
um so if you are new here and just want
to get started so just click on register
for free
and you will be if just with your gmail
account you can create a free account
and you can get started
so you can click on the courses tab here
to get access to all the courses
there will be some suggestions based on
whatever you do so these are like
suggestions for me here particularly
and these are some projects that
artificial intelligence algorithm is
suggesting me but you can get started
with introduction to bioinformatics so
this is the course introduction to
bioinformatics which
um is just the beginning and the first
step to do it
to get started with bioinformatics to
know what it is to know what it really
entails what are the various
domains
involved
and you see these are some of the three
lessons of this particular introduction
to bioinformatics which is big data
bioinformatics and healthcare and
translation and bioinformatics
and after you complete this particular
course what you should do is go for the
bytes and the molecule support so you
can just
type here like bytes and molecules and
you see it suggests like course number
two bits and molecules why am i
suggesting you this because this is a
kind of citizen science and science
communication course transformed in the
domain of bioinformatics so here you
will get to learn about the various
areas in which mathematics is applied
what are the various exciting drug
domains and opportunities for you to get
started with bioinformatics so you as
you can see that how
you can decipher codes from the
molecules that's the dna how it stores
information how bioinformatics is used
in citizen science projects what sort of
data are we looking at from these
molecules study more about the dna and
its biochemistry
about proteins then slowly we start
moving into the omics domain such as
genomics transcriptomics meta genomics
and if you click on load more you will
get more suggestions here uh we have a
course on bioinformatics and precision
medicine we have space on this and
astronaut health that's the kind of area
where i am interested in and i work so
basically whenever a human being goes to
space for exploration because the
environment is so different they start
getting affected
on various levels we do know that they
have some issues with their bones and
muscles but at the same time in the dna
level at the genetic level there are
various things going wrong which we
can't see from outside but once we start
looking into the omics and apply
bioinformatics to actually gain those
insights we see that there's suddenly a
new field of science which has erupted
and there's so many people so many
organizations working on it so that's
really the power of bioinformatics
and to do bioinformatics we do require
some coding skills to make algorithms to
make our lives easier so we also have a
few courses in r and python but if
you're like me who doesn't really want
to write 1000 lines of code for
their work
here's the solution to all of you this
is the server t-bio info which we call
the t-bio info platform
i will paste the
link in the chat so that you can also
explore it you need to register it and
if you face any issues with the
registering registration and the
communication or usage of this platform
just send us an email at marketing at
pine dot bio or you can also send it to
marketing at
omicslogic.com
or you can also send it to support
at the rate find out bio and our team
will reach out to you and support you
with
getting started and using the platform
but to use the platform you can also go
through the courses and learn how to use
it so i will give you a quick overview
of the platform here so as you can see
it has various sections such as nts data
that's next generation sequencing data
processing mass spectroscopy um their
structural biology for all the 3d
visualizations and domains and folds and
finally we have the exciting segment
called the data integration and model
modeling which has
concepts like multi-omics combining all
the different domains domain and
extracting meaning out of it we have
data mining which
incorporates both supervised and
unsupervised machine learning algorithms
various factor regression analysis and
other tools and technologies we have
separate segments for virology single
cell analysis cancer biology and also
metagenomics now let me give you an
example of
how this
entire server work with the help of a
demo pipeline so let's use this
particular demo rna-seq pipeline which
takes help for
which takes help of a publication a
public
uh
published
paper on cancer biology
so
here you can see what this platform
looks like basically and all of these
buttons are a tool or an algorithm in
itself so here instead of coding these
tools or writing lines after lines to
really connect these
various tools you just now have to click
button so here you can see once you
click on start you get started there's a
picture which
like explains you what rnsc is what we
are trying to do
and now you see once you click on start
automatically depending upon the data
that you insert it's glowing yellow it's
highlighting in yellow so those are the
algorithms which you can choose from so
this is an artificially intelligent
platform which suggests you that kind of
parts that you should choose to reach to
your desired output here so you see as i
am building the pipeline and connecting
the algorithms i am getting different
suggestions
and as i am clicking on it suppose this
one you get some tutorial on it the link
to all the papers which
made these algorithms
um and you see the arrow mark shows that
the pipeline is being built so pipeline
is nothing but a series of
algorithms connected to each other to
generate biologically meaningful result
from our data which we are inserting
basically an ngs data here
um so i will just quickly go over it
without taking a lot of time because
explaining them are in itself a complete
program which you can find on the
learn platform as well as you can also
enroll yourself for various
mentor guided programs with where our
vendors walk you through all of these
concepts and all of these technical
terms so once you have run the pipeline
and it's complete you see you get some
downloadable files here
and you can see the size of these files
these are already over some megabytes
and even sometimes if it's a real
project or a bulk project that you're
doing it can also go to gigabytes so
really the
major implication of using this platform
is the space availability you really
can't run all of these algorithms
together on your personal computer
because that won't just support um this
tbifo server runs on several parallel
gpus located at the university of haifa
and tbrc which supports these sort of a
high end analysis which is required in
nowadays biological research and when
you sign up for this platform you get 5
terabytes of space
which you can use for your research work
and there are various
subscription levels for this which you
can explore again in the learn portal
here by clicking on the pricing domain
so
i think that was a pretty quick but
uh helpful introduction to the dband
server and all of the courses and all of
the projects that is available on this
platform utilizes the t by info server
if there's a detailed tutorial for how
to use the server and
it's a good opportunity for all of you
to get started
without needing to write even one line
of code which is unique as well as very
very very much beneficial
so i would stop my presentation right
here and
transfer it back to maria who would like
to continue and
share some more information and insights
with all of you so over to you maria
one second
here no problem
and here i am again
so
um i would like to invite invite you all
for the
symposium that will take place on
march
31st
and april 1st
and will include several
keynotes and pay no discussions
and several interesting topics to
biotechnology students and other
students
from
bio area
can
get interesting so
educational research industry
applications of bioinformatics such as
pharmaceutical
and agriculture
and also
um you can learn about
technologies career opportunities and
more
so
you can register for free to attend the
symposium and
these three opportunities
will be shown and
here
um among the speakers will be professors
from several universities as georgetown
university medical school
um
university of brasilia
and also
some research centers
and as earth life science institute of
japan
name
nasa
and others
and
like inner industry expert
and
partners
and here are some of the speakers
um
that you can
get interested and learn more about what
they are going to talk
scientists and researchers and also
space biology experts
and
i would like to
uh invite to
all of
you that already study and work
with bioinformatics and you wanted to
show your projects internationally
um you know that in brazil something
that is
very taken to account is international
experiences and you can
have a poster presentation session
in which the best one will be awarded
this one was the
awarded of 2021
and you can send your abstract to the
competition and receive feedbacks from
experienced professionals in the area
and also
get network with others
so
if you
can
oh if you want to participate you can
follow some steps
and i will show you in this
website of the symposia
that is
here
so
you can submit your abstract for poster
presentation competition here
and also
register for free to participate in the
virtual omics research symposium
and
participate
yeah
thank you for sending the link
and i would like to i would like to
thank you everyone for being here with
me
and listening to me and listening to the
opportunities opportunities
of
pine biotech
and omex logic
and if any one of you
want to talk to me for some reason
i will send you my linkedin
here
bye
thank you so much maria again that was a
really great presentation and
their
talk was so much insightful
and
i hope that
all our
audience today who are
sticking around with us
even right now did really enjoy the
session and also got to know about the
various opportunities and resources that
they can utilize for their own benefits
so quickly i will go over a few more
exciting opportunities and events coming
up which you can be a part of
so once you sign up for the upcoming
research symposium you also get access
to all of these
workshops that are planned for march so
there will be sessions
dedicated on genomic surveillance of
star spot 2 single cell
ngs data analysis and project support
machine learning economics there will be
some special
workshops for faculties and
mentors
and also on cancer mutations and how you
can analyze them using ngs data
which all will lead up to the mega event
that is the homicide symposium on march
31st and april 1st so
i have shared the link with all of you
in the chat section you can also scan
this qr code to register for the
symposium it's completely free to listen
the keynote speakers talks in the
symposium
and
here's the qr code to
sign up for
the poster presentation
you can submit your abstracts
until march 10 to 2022.
um there are a few rules which are very
easy to follow such as the abstract
length should be 150 to 200 words it
should be
segregated into four segments such as
objective methods results and conclusion
um just to make it more organized and
easy to
read
to make all the abstract standard we
recommend to use the font monster at and
size 12 points
and please upload a pdf
file so that it is not
it just does doesn't get
disoriented when we
switch machines so a pdf format will be
standard and very easy and good to
analyze and read
so
we have a great online presence on any
of the social medias which you are a
part of you can find us on facebook
instagram linkedin
youtube of course and also twitter we
also have various groups which you can
definitely join and have regular
conversation with peers students
faculties and experts from
different parts of the globe
so
right now we are towards the [ __ ] end of
today's session
your
opinion matters the most to us so i
would recommend all of you to again scan
this qr code
or
go to the link that is mentioned in the
screen to give us your feedback what do
you feel about this ionic sessions and
how you feel we can improve in the days
to come
now here's a heads up for the upcoming
psionic session
this will be helped
by
mr darko marin who is a data scientist
ai and statistics expert
from the ethers group fukuoka in japan
and he will be talking about the
informatics and data science challenges
which students usually face
and what are the ways to address them
how to get over those
problems and how to solve them it is
scheduled to happen on march 11 2022 at
6 30 pm indian standard time which is 7
a.m in central standard time
um unfortunately we can't mention the
other time zones but you can definitely
convert it using any of the converting
tools that is available online
so on that note it's
uh
it's the end of today's cyanic session
well from the bottom of my heart once
again i would like to thank all of you
who
were a part of today's session it was
lovely to see and interact all of you
today um thank you so much to maria for
your time and your wonderful
presentation for your explanation of all
the resources and the
training courses available on the
omixlogic platform and also for sharing
all the vital insights and information
for the upcoming omics research
symposium
at this point of time i would request
all of you present in our audience to
feel free to ask me any questions that
you might have so you can put your
question
um in the chat section any feedbacks
would definitely mean a lot of lot to us
thank you so much for the wonderful
messages in the chat we really
appreciate it
and for any questions feel free to
put them in the chat
if not
then
that's cut in calls from
us at psyonix
we will see you again on march 11th with
another exciting session
and another great
expert talk
until then
stay happy stay safe
enjoy your work into your day and i wish
all of you good health and good luck and
we will again see you soon
on march 11
take care and bye
you